Hi, Nora.
Hi.
Thank you for meeting me on such short notice about Abby.
Sure.
Come on in. Have a seat.
Abby, Abby.
We miss Abby.
I haven't talked to her for a while.
Is everything okay?
Not really.
She seems to be struggling.
Lateness and attendance issues.
Did she have any trouble getting to work when she was on your team?
Not once we worked out the telework system.
Abby is a good worker.
Period.
But, she has health issues that she has to manage, and she needs flexibility.
We worked at a schedule where she could see her psychotherapist regularly...
...and then work the hours where she was feeling best,...
...even sometimes if it was late at night.
Sometimes, the meds she's on...
...have side effects that just make it difficult for her.
Okay.
So, she's a person with a disability and you provided flexibility as an accommodation?
Yes.
Did that present issues to other members of your team?
No, not really.
I have working parents, people going back to school...
...and any number of other reasons why my team members request flexible work arrangements.
No biggie.
Got it.
Yeah, I just don't think that her new supervisor...
...is as comfortable with flexible work arrangements.
Thank you, Nora.
You're welcome.